تضاعفت حالات جدري القردة ثلاث مرات في
أوروبا خلال الأسبوعين الماضيين ، دعونا
نلقي نظرة على أعداد حالات جدري القردة
في أوروبا والعالم منذ
منتصف مايو 90٪ من
الحالات المؤكدة مختبريًا على مستوى العالم في أوروبا ،
أي 4500 حالة في أوروبا.  كانت
أعلى تعداد الحالات في المملكة المتحدة
وألمانيا وإسبانيا الآن ، دعونا نلقي نظرة
على من يصاب بجدري القردة في أوروبا ، 99 في
المائة من الحالات كانت من الذكور
ومعظمهم من الرجال المثليين ، ومعظمهم تتراوح أعمارهم بين 21
و 40 عامًا ، كانت هناك بعض
الحالات بين  أفراد الأسرة
والمخالطين غير الجنسيين وأيضًا لدى الأطفال الذين
يسمعون عن أعداد الحالات المرتفعة هذه
قد يجعلك تتساءل
عما إذا كنا نتجه إلى وضع شبيه بالفيروس
والإجابة على ذلك وفقًا
لخبراء الصحة العامة هي أنه ليس من الصعب
جدًا الإصابة بجدري القردة من  الحصول على علاج
لجدري القردة ، عادة ما يكون لديك نوع
من الجلد إلى الجلد ، لا
يجب أن يكون جنسيًا ولكن الاتصال الوثيق أو
شيء مثل مشاركة المناشف أو الملاءات ،
لذلك يقول الخبراء  لا تتجه إلى
وضع يشبه الطمع ولكن لا يزال يتعين على الناس
توخي الحذر ، فنحن بالتأكيد نريد
الاحتفاظ بهذه الحالة العد التنازلي بدلاً من
الرجوع إليك